hey guys it's max and from max tech and
today we are doing another unbiased
camera comparison between the no 10 plus
the 7 pro and the 10s max so I swapped
out vadim for angelica because she is
unbiased not that I wanna say woody was
really biased but we follow these camera
changes year to year model the model and
she does not so we want to see which of
these phones do the best just based off
of the images themselves now we also
swapped out the letters so that it's not
the same letter for the same phone each
time so just look at the image see which
one is the best write it down because we
want to hear your guys's opinions at the
end down in the comments section below
let's jump into it we're starting out
with a selfie image right here so which
one looks the best to you and why I
think B looks the best the shadows on a
are just way too intense with C
everything looks very very flat both B
everything is really bright and clear
and your skin looks very very smooth I
think that looks best okay and we have a
landscape shot so we have
bridge-building I don't like see it
looks very very kind of faded and bland
and there's barely any details with a
and B the detail is really great both a
it definitely looks more saturated when
you look at the sky I think it looks the
best and this one these guys standing
under the bridge we have this waterfall
getting just hit with light so very dark
shadows bright highlights we have the
greenery right here this is hard both a
and B you look really nice
I don't like C again I think the shadows
are really really dark when you look at
the the stairs and the rocks at the
bottom
everything looks too dark like you can't
we see a whole lot of detail anymore but
you Amy I think I like B more and now we
also have another really high dynamic
range situation for sure a B and C like
Noah standing in the light so the
sunlight stadium directly and it looks
way
like super Subaru blown out his face and
his shirt just completely lost detail
and contrast it definitely looks the
best and this is a selfie and extreme
selfie so I'm standing in that same
shade which one would you want to keep
in your phone Sam everyone this was a
shocker we were not expecting this next
we have this is a zoomin photo so we
zoomed in pretty much all the way or all
the way on these photos which one would
you choose
obviously the colors look the best I
guess on B but I like see the most
because even though you're super super
super zoomed in you can still see all
the details on the tree and on the tower
it's much easier to work with that like
if you want to add more saturation to it
it's easier to do that than to try to
add detail without it looking way too
okay so this is a landscape shot which
one do you like better and why yeah I
like a the most but see it's really
really dark the shadows you kind of lose
a lot of detail and the trees and
everything and then between a and B a
just looks way more dimensional and
sharp yeah next one this is a portrait
shot so using the portrait mode that's
supposed to blur out the background what
do you think well you can still see the
detail of the tree behind it super well
and the cloud I'll just say it's in a
world it didn't work for this one you
you know I shot the images and yeah
I'm between a B it's definitely a when
you look at the cloud in the tree in the
background a did a much better job
blurring the next one here is a food
shot so we have some sushi here and
these are all untouched religious to me
I definitely think C looks the best with
a
I think the white balance is really
pretty sure that plate is a white plate
it is yes that was a white plate it does
not look white at all um yeah I think C
definitely looks the best so this one is
a macro shot we also have sushi here
it's a close-up I'm gonna see looks
really good the detail looks really good
but it's pretty dark I'm gonna I'm gonna
go and for this next one this is using
the standard lens backlit as you can see
when you look at their faces there's way
more like detail and everything on B now
we have a portrait shot this time we
have two separate subjects and there are
people and yeah what do you think I
think C looks the best I think their
skin tones and everything look at the
most realistic and smooth nice okay the
next one is another portrait shot this
time with just Alina in it I think C
looks the best I hate the V looks awful
in this it looks just insane and like
you put a filter on it it looks way too
contrasty see see looks really good and
now we have another portrait shot but
this is a selfie portrait going against
shooting against the Sun here next one
is this is kind of like a sunset
landscape shot hey doesn't look bad see
looks pretty bad
there's like barely any saturation at
all it looks good but we definitely
looks the best okay and this one is
there any possum set there were some
ducks that were swimming up I don't like
see at all again it looks pretty flat
one dimensional and B are very very
different
there's only way more detail and a that
you can see far away and like under the
water it's way more detailed but I
honestly like the look of be better and
then this is the sign is basically sat
right behind the horizon here and
shooting against the Sun a selfie
definitely way better he looks super
alive the colors everything the detail
everything's amazing his skin looks
great she looks
oh I would never want to look like that
he looks like a zombie and this one is
Sun is already down so another kind of
landscape shot lots of lights already
lit up it looks really bad with all the
like dark areas you can't see anything
there's no detail I think be looks
really nice but the lights on the
buildings are kind of blowing out so
this is an extreme dark environment so
which one do you think looks better it
looks awful you can't see anything at
all you've been just swallowed whole by
the darkness can't see anything in terms
of the whole background and everything
see looks really really good but you
can't really see yourself be honestly
the photo itself doesn't look good but
at least at least you can see your face
and it's a selfie so I guess I have to
do it B this is already completely dark
outside the Sun is set we're closer to
the buildings here the lights are really
shining I think I like see the most be
looks a little crazy eh once again like
the dark shadows and everything just
swallow up all the detail can't see
anything really anymore see looks really
good so Angelica chose the ones she
prefers now it's time for you guys so go
ahead and pause this video right now and
we want you guys to let us know down in
the comments section below
we want to hear your guys's opinions and
so Angelica you had 11 for me then you
had 5 for C and 4 for a now I have to
reveal something to you guys we did not
mix up the numbers so sorry for her for
not telling you guys the truth but in
fact we kept the numbers the same so
they're all the same one that is because
it's a royal pain to reveal which one is
which if we have to go through 20 photos
photo by photo and telling you which one
is which it takes forever and you guys
won't even comment anymore
take your list so we have eight is the
iPhone B is the Galaxy Note 10.1 plus
seven Pro is the iPhone I give it the
least amount and you're an iPhone user
you have an iPhone 7 it's so if we took
your iPhone 7 we know it's okay were you
surprised by the results of which one
was which
yeah for sure I mean for one OK Samsung
Wow go use the Samsung photos B they
looked really really good it looks
really good especially someone like
front-facing selfie
we were surprised as well in a couple of
different areas and we were surprised by
the iPhone as well yeah the dark so I'm
not gonna give a lot of my opinions in
this video we're gonna make a separate
video going over stuff and some changes
that were made and some really shocking
things so make sure you guys are
subscribed notifications enabled but
what I will say is I was expecting some
of these dark shots to not look as good
with the iPhone but there are some other
shots that I was just shocked by the
Dean was shocked by what we saw them and
we didn't go and pick and choose these
images we didn't shoot a hundred and
choose 20 to try to flip it one way I
have literally shot most of the image of
that shot were in here we just had to
cut it down to 20 and give it a good
variety but yeah if the results were
very interesting so Thank You Angelica
for being a part of this maybe we'll do
more of these in the future let us know
down in the comment section below if you
guys enjoy these kind of videos we want
to hear you guys opinion and if you did
enjoy it hit that thumbs up button if
you guys want to see more videos like
this one we do have one where we
compared an iPhone and the s10 plus
there's a little box right over there
and then another video you guys can
check out and of course we're gonna have
more videos on the Galaxy Note 10.1 and
with Mac's tech and we'll see you guys
in the next
[Music]